sommes en ligne actuellement avec
adriannonjon bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes chercheur à l'INALCO
spécialiste de l'Ukraine on voyait un
ces images de ce qu'on voit militaire
russe qui se trouve à moins de 30 km de
la capitale qu'est-ce que cela signifie
selon vous est-ce que l'on peut
s'attendre à une grosse offensive sur
Kiev dans les prochaines heures
tout à fait je pense qu'en fait la
stratégie russe reste inchangée devant
et en fait Vladimir Poutine reste devant
le fait accompli c'est-à-dire que voyant
la résistance ukrainienne s'organisait
résister avec bravoure il a envie
maintenant d'en finir le plus rapidement
possible sachant que les négociations
traînent que le aide occidental
s'organise donc pour lui ne s'agit plus
simplement
d'avancer mais de finalement écraser la
résistance ukrainienne écrasez l'état
ukrainien et comme le disait votre
collègue juste avant il s'agit
maintenant de l'écraser les défenseurs
Ukrainiens non pas seulement sur la
ligne de front mais le village par
village bâtiment par bâtiment et rue
paru on a on a écouté le discours de la
présidente du Parlement européen qui est
en session extraordinaire en ce moment
même qui a évidemment redit son soutien
le soutien de l'Union européenne au
président Zelenski qui est lui aussi
s'est exprimé en visioconférence en
direct devant le Parlement le président
Hélène ski qui demande un soutien
concret à l'Union européenne pour pour
que l'Ukraine puisse adhérer donc à
l'Union européenne
oui tout à fait c'est tout l'enjeu en
fait des événements aujourd'hui et le
fait que le volodymeersky réclame une
adhésion d'urgence à l'Union européenne
pourrait basculer faire basculer la
balance un petit peu même si on peut
toujours émettre des réserves sachant
que ça pourrait enrager Vladimir Poutine
et les Russes car il s'agit pour eux
d'une ligne rouge car qui dit adhésion à
l'Union européenne pour les Russes dit
forcément à des ions à l'OTAN néanmoins
si une si les européens devaient
intégrer l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne
par urgence sachez que quand même il y
aura une procédure assez longue dans le
devenir parce qu'une adhésion à l'Union
européenne ne se fait pas du jour au
lendemain il faut que les pays candidats
remplissent un certain nombre de
critères à voir si les Européens sont
prêts à accélérer le processus sachant
que et en plus il faut obtenir une
majorité or nous avons quand même un
certain nombre d'États dans l'Union
européenne la Hongrie la première qui
refus qui ont toujours refusé que
l'Ukraine
pour des raisons politiques
ont refusé que l'Ukraine rejoigne
l'Union européenne jusqu'à présent on a
parlé de carquis ou des bombes se sont
écrasés sur le centre de la ville
d'ailleurs le président Hélène ski a
parlé de cette place de la Liberté dans
son discours devant le Parlement des
civils russophone qui sont bombardés la
ligne rouge a été franchie selon vous
par la Russie
la ligne rouge en fait a été franchie
dès le début des opérations à vrai dire
mais aujourd'hui comme comme j'ai pu le
dire juste avant on est dans une fuite
en avant une un jusqu'au-boutisme de la
part de Vladimir Poutine et vous il
décide il a décidé d'écraser le plus
rapidement possible toute forme de
résistance donc peu importe si des
civils seront pris entre les feux de
tant pis pour les Russes si des des
victimes heureux civiles sont à déplorer
leur objectif est de prendre l'Ukraine
le plus rapidement possible Adrien
longjon est-ce que selon vous Vladimir
Poutine avait anticipé une telle
résistance de la part des
Ukrainiens
absolument pas je pense d'où le d'où ça
prudence et le fait d'avoir mobilisé dès
le début en fait seulement des éléments
légers aussi bien des blindés que des
petites forces type commando
l'état-major russe à sous-estimer la
résistance
ukrainienne et aujourd'hui voyons que
l'invasion piétine Vladimir Poutine
essaye à tout prix de nouvelles
manœuvres et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui il se concentre davantage
maintenant sur l'encerclement du rivage
de la mer d'azote avec la ville de Mario
Paul qui tient toujours tête et ce dans
l'objectif peut-être s'il n'arrive pas à
obtenir le remplacement de vos leadersky
par un président pour russe peut-être
constitué avoir cette région de
nouvelles réussites qu'il revendiquait
dès 2014-2015 alors justement les les
regards sont tournés vers Kiev la
capitale bien sûr vers carquif la
deuxième ville du pays mais on apprend
que Mario Paul et est activement
bombardé aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
d'électricité dans dans la ville
pouvez-vous nous rappeler la la place
strat logique de cette ville de l'est de
l'Ukraine sur les bords de la mère
d'Azov et peut-être éventuellement cette
offensive russe qui qui grignote qui
grignote encore un morceau de l'Ukraine
bien sûr tout d'abord en fait dans la
ville de Mario Paul en fait qu'on
constitue l'un des poumons économiques
de l'Ukraine c'est une ville qui
concentre non seulement des activités
portuaires c'est de là en fait nous
partent les principaux échanges vers
vers l'étranger l'Ukraine à partir de là
exporte du grain mais notamment de la
coque et de l'acier gras et aussi abrite
un certain cette ville abrite un certain
nombre de d'usines très importantes dont
certaines appartiennent à l'oligarque
rhinote arkmetov avec ses AJAX et plus
généralement en fait cette ville de
Mario Paul tout ça symbolise aussi la
nouvelle Russie la nouvelle l'idée de
faire ce à travers Mario Paul une
jonction entre les éléments russes qui
proviennent de Crimée et du lion de base
pourrait atteindre utiliser pourrait à
terme mettre sur place sur pied cette
nouvelle région qui en fait renvoie à un
imaginaire historique ou en fait ça
revient c'est Catherine II avait déjà
avec voulu constituer cette région
constituer cette région pour pouvoir
prendre un pied sur les mers les mers
chaudes la Méditerranée mais aussi à
terme conquérir la ville de
Constantinople qui appartenait à
l'Empire ottoman et faire de la Russie
en fait cette mousse de cette nouvelle
troisième Rome qui serait le centre de
l'orthodoxie
merci beaucoup Adrien donjon d'avoir été
en direct sur France 24 pour nous aider
à comprendre cette guerre en Ukraine je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'inal commercial à vous et bonne
journée